hey everybody it's Jesse
and everybody this happened a Good
Friday
kind of nice end of the week
looking forward to to the weekend
although I'll still be coding over the
weekend I'm sure it's the same with all
of you there's always always something
to work on
today see I want to let you know about a
few things before we get started so one
really cool code school is having a free
weekend so they're courses you go in
there and take their courses for free so
check that out it's cooked code school
comm slash free weekend and thanks to
Patrick for putting that in the live
chat and in the slack channel for for
our live stream so check that out not an
official endorsement because I haven't
taken courses from code school so I
can't say personally whether or not it's
a good resource but I checked out some
of their courses just the you know the
names of of it and I look pretty cool so
if you if you don't have anything else
going on this weekend then seems like a
good opportunity there's one more thing
okay I remember I should write this
stuff down beforehand so I don't forget
I so this is the style guide and I think
I've shown this before on live strangers
the style guide for the the university
that I work for so I made this and this
was actually the first react project
that I ever worked on the reason that I
bring this up now is because I had a
comment on a one of my videos and
someone had said they found
a typo in the style guide and they they
were going to submit a pull request to
fix it but they couldn't find the repo
and I thought that was odd and I thought
well maybe I made it private it turns
out I did so I made that repo private
I'm not sure why but I suspect since it
was my first react project I didn't want
to look like a noob so I just made it
private so now that I'm live on YouTube
looking like a noob every day I decided
there's no reason that it should be
private so I did make it public so that
repo is now public on you can find it on
my github account which I don't know if
I have that linked or not it's linked
from my YouTube channel which i think is
like linked in the video but anyway if
you're interested you can check it out I
wouldn't really spend too much time
doing if you wanted like let's say to
contribute I wouldn't spend too much
time on this one because after looking
at the code I think I'd really like to
redo it and and redo it to the point of
maybe it's better just to start a
completely new project this was done
using create react app but I ejected it
really you know really soon into it was
maybe like the third or fourth commit
said I ran eject and I think I was just
curious and wanted to do some things
with the setup I wanted to use sass so
and at the time I couldn't figure out
how to get sass to work without ejecting
so anyway it probably has really old
versions of everything all the the
packages and things are old and it's
using materialized and not material UI
and I think I'd rather go with material
UI if I'm doing things in react so
anyway just thought I'd let you know
since there was some interest in
in the style guide I didn't realize
anybody was looking at it but I guess at
least one person was alright so I'm
gonna say hi and check the lab chat
really quick okay cool Patrick says he's
done some previous free weekends on with
code school and he said it's a pretty
good resource so awesome okay
so let's get started I do want to say my
normal type of kind of thing for any new
people that are watching or maybe you've
only watched a few times and haven't
heard this before the point of this
stream in particular is to just show me
in doing my everyday work as a front-end
developer I'm employed full-time by
University and so it's not necessarily a
tutorial but I try to explain what I'm
doing as much as possible so if you're a
beginner then it might still be
worthwhile for you to watch even if this
is maybe a little bit more advanced than
than what you're currently doing because
I'll you know I try to explain things
and also you know not everything is done
during the stream so from stream to
stream there may be things that I work
on are things that change that obviously
I didn't get you know recorded there
will be interruptions occasionally
people knock on my door they call me and
I have to stop so just wanted to get
that all out of the way right off the
bat if you've been watching for a while
I know you know that but occasionally I
do have people that are I don't know it
seems like maybe from the comments that
that they don't they've never heard that
before or realized with what I'm doing
with this stream so I just want to make
sure when expectations are correct with
what we're trying to do here
alright so having said all that I
actually have changed very little since
yesterday
and in fact Patrick submitted a pull
request and basically I don't I don't
know that I want to say fix the issues
we were having with with standard KS
yesterday but I guess kind of worked
around it all right and here's the
workaround so you can see it in two
places first place is here at the top of
our file
we can set some some es Lin rules and in
this case we're setting the global
onmouseover on Mouse outs right so this
would these were we're giving us errors
saying they're not defined now there's
no errors and then also we can do that
in our package JSON so you can see under
standard Global's
we put all these things one of them
being state so when we were defining
state and let's see what we're doing it
okay when we're defining state like this
we were getting an undefined error so
now we don't get that anymore and going
forward for anybody submitting pool
requests I think the best way to proceed
with this is if you if you use something
here with especially if you use it you
know like this with the arrow function
it's it's not going to it's not gonna
recognize that right forward for a lot
of reasons that we went over yesterday
and I'm not gonna go into because I'm
not exactly I'm not even exactly sure
what the reasons are but it has
something to do with updates to yarn NPM
so what we will do then is in our global
up here within the file so not in
package JSON we're gonna put everything
that's giving that's giving us errors or
that we know ahead of time we'll
probably give us errors this avoids us
having to bind so normally we would bind
these things we bind this for each one
of these in our constructor right so for
every single click for onmouseover for
onmouseout that would be two separate
lines so we still have to do something
but it's it's less than what we normally
have to do and it's way up at the top
and it's not down here you know kind of
clutter
things up so we can basically do it all
in one line and just throw it up here
it'll work if you're going to use
something on more than one component
then it can go here in our package JSON
so that's the that's kind of the
workaround for now thanks Patrick for
for doing that that was really good
thinking actually because that's I mean
it's just a very simple solution and
this is certainly a debatable thing so I
don't want to put this forward it's like
this is the solution that everybody
should use because it's there certainly
might be a different way or better way
to get these working without errors and
it's debatable as to whether or not this
is even the best way to do things you
know the older way of using the
constructor is still in the react
documentation binding with this inside
the constructor is in the react
documentation it does mention this
property initializer syntax but it does
it says that it's experimental so this
is certainly not the standard way I like
it
I've been doing it that way for the last
at least the last two projects I think
including this one and so I've gotten
used to it I like it it's more concise
and I don't have a problem telling you
know being able to know what's going on
I have read you know online some people
saying that they're not sure you know
what's going on when they see that but I
don't know I think it's pretty
straightforward so I'd like to keep
using that but I certainly understand it
let's say if you were to submit a pull
request using the older way of doing
things I'm not opposed to that I'm not
gonna say that you need to change it so
with with that said we're gonna move
forward when I do things you know I'll
do it with the property initializer
syntax
but I just stuff I definitely don't want
to put that forward like this is the way
to do it because I don't think that
that's at least from what I've
researched it's it's certainly not a
decided issue yet
okay
so actually I just got a link from so
then put a link in about this buying
issue so I'm gonna I'm gonna open that
up on my other screen so I don't forget
but I'm not gonna go over it right now
because I've already talked for a long
time without doing any coding so I'd
like to get started on the coding but
thank you Ben I will check that out as
soon as I'm done with with the stream
and what we were working on yesterday so
just to catch everyone up we're building
great with react we use create react app
and we've got a bunch of other kind of
nice tools that we're working with to
autoformat our code and so the basic
function of what we're building is to
provide resources like logo images and
information to people who work at this
university that I work at and also allow
them through a form to submit requests
for work so we're working today on this
section and so yesterday we we set some
things up to be able to attract the
scroll position of the user on the page
and to also get the values of the Y
position of each of these these are all
h3s that I'm highlighting each of these
age threes the plan today is to change
this side menu here to reflect the names
of these headers and to have as we
scroll down have the appropriate name be
highlighted okay and not only that but
we'd like it if if you happen to click
on one of those names that it would
scroll automatically to that section
okay so we're gonna be adapting this
this component comes in material UI and
I think it's called
pepper immaterial UI so it's not exactly
intended for this kind of thing but it's
close enough that I think we can adapt
it pretty pretty easily I don't think
it'll take too much work to do this so
that's where we're at that's what's
what's going on so if you want to follow
along in the repo we're in the planning
guide Jas is where we'll be at for
probably all of this maybe we'll put
some styles in a sass file but other
than that we're gonna be hanging out in
this file so I'm gonna close our folder
tree view and just give us some more
space I'll make this a bit bigger for
you all let's see so we need
see I need I need to get my mind wrapped
around where we left off I had meetings
all morning and so I didn't I didn't get
a chance to work on this
okay all right so currently our header
positions are here in an array and then
our scroll position is here under scroll
Y so let's change let's change the
values here for this step or just to
make it a bit more obvious with the what
this is supposed to do I keep having to
explain what it's going to do because we
still have all these default things here
so let's change that and for now I think
I'm just going to I'm just gonna
manually put put the sections in I think
if we had more sections it would be a
better idea to grab the text of each h3
and then loop over let's say we had an
array of the text for each of the h3 s
loop over that and then create these but
since we only have what three or four
I'm just gonna put them in here and
all right
I'll just copy and paste these actually
this will be faster let me drag this
over on my other screen and it'll be a
lot faster for me to copy and paste that
I may shorten some of these up we'll see
how how they display but I'd rather not
have them wrap onto another line so
we'll see if that's necessary and we
need to add few more just one more right
there's only four
and let's give this a step index of
three
and they should be
two three yes if he should be three as
well all right see how that looks
oops
okay that's actually and not bad
now that I look at this I think it's
worded a bit I don't like how it's
worded right so it says please follow
these guidelines and so it says plan
ahead proof the job in a timely manner
so those are like saying here's what you
do right you have to plan ahead you have
to prove drove in a timely manner and
then this just says budget information I
think it might be better if it just said
budget right like you need to budget and
then obviously this is information about
budgeting normally I don't make
decisions about content we have content
editors that just tell me what to do but
I think I'm gonna change that and we'll
just see how it goes they'll definitely
make me change it back they don't like
that
budget
following that same logic services would
probably go better up here's a planet
and I guess would be better if it's a
plan ahead to services budget proof the
job in a timely manner
maybe services could go after budget I'm
gonna leave it alone for now oh this is
not really my area
I'll let the content people deal with
that but now that we kind of after we
had it kind of displayed over here it
just it looks looked a little odd to me
I think we can I think we can get rid of
this one two three four I mean the steps
are somewhat logical but right now at
least the position of services throws
things off a bit a bit because that's
obviously not the last step so we're
going to remove this reset and we're
gonna remove this click a step and then
I guess we'll remove these as well
so you don't need yeah this entire
paragraph we can get rid of and
you know if you get rid of this
yeah hopefully this won't break things
and I think we don't need these buttons
anymore not
okay great so we have gotten rid of that
good okay so it's still doing some
things that we don't really want it to
do but we'll get we got something
through many a oops forgot to set my
Pomodoro timer it's so let's set it now
better late than never so we may need to
let's check out the options in material
UI if there's not an option to change
how this looks then we can always just
use some CSS to override things I'd
rather not directly modify the component
in material UI so I think it would be
better in this case to just change
essentially just hide this with CSS
assuming that there's no option and we
need
okay it looks like we we may be able to
put whatever we want inside the step
okay so right now we're using this step
button which I'm assuming that's that's
what's giving us our this kind of circle
with the checkbox there so if we changed
it and we didn't use a step button but
instead I mean we replace this with
anything really if we leave the on click
the unclick yeah I don't think we'll be
changing state
yeah I don't think will change state
well we want to do unclick you scroll to
a certain position yeah so let's just
first let's try changing this let's just
make it a span for now just see what it
what it looks like all right cool
so let's change all of these two spans
see how that looks whoa all right still
want to get rid of these but okay not
that we want to add add some styling to
that but we've gotten rid of the other
thing so
okay I want to see how this looks now in
the
and he's you know
okay
I'm gonna try
let me make sure I'm gonna make this a
bit smaller so we can see both both
things I believe we can scroll
was it
no let's just be honored right no this
whole table is not a function
hmm
I thought we'd use this we'll use
okay so that's just giving us our
let's try with window oh we need sorry
let's try that again
I remember how to do it now there we go
okay so we can do this and it'll scroll
us around so if you saw that I'm just
typing in different values for scroll
top I'm setting scroll top to whatever I
want it to be okay so that's that's how
we do it you'd see I was a little
confused at first and I was trying to
set it in here and dev tools kept
telling me that it wasn't a function and
it just didn't register at first okay
so first we're gonna do it like this a
nicer way to do this would be to
gradually scroll so maybe we'll
implement some sort of smooth scrolling
I have done that on previous projects
it's possible I use jQuery for it but it
I think it would be worthwhile for me to
look up how I did it before and see if I
could just adapt that so here's what we
want to do on click me grab this so on
click we want to
see
you want to go scroll top equals this
set or this state and let's go with call
that header physicians okay so to go
this state header positions
and
header positions and we can actually use
the step index right we have we do have
the step in ducks here correct yeah so
we can use the step index
no we can't because I'm not setting the
step index anymore
all right I may have to rethink I'm
doing this for now I'm just gonna
manually put a few of these in and
that'll at least be able to test the
next step
okay
let's see cool alright so this is
working it's taking us to the sections
gray awesome okay so that's I think that
was actually the second step as I
explained it before but that ended up
being easier to implement so one of the
things that we wanted to do is implement
it and the next thing is just going to
be to highlight this if we're in that
the right area you know kind of so as we
scroll down and that highlight whether
or not something is highlighted will be
determined by our Y our scroll Y and our
header positions so let's see so I think
we should give position of active
section
and
let's see zero so we'll use the index of
each section I think that that we yeah
that should be the easiest way so
section 1 which would be 0 right because
we're zero indexing section 1 will be
the default because that's just going to
be the top of the page basically the top
we're not including that first h2 but
this will work so active section is 0 so
let's see
all right let me let me just kind of
explain out loud what I'm thinking for
the next step so we will make the active
the active section will be based on a
comparison between the scroll Y and the
header positions that comparison will
happen every time handle scroll runs
will do that same comparison so I
suppose inside handle scroll will do
that will it'll be something like like a
note like this set state but it'll be
maybe a switch statement that may be the
best way to do it because there's going
to be conditions so if scroll Y is
between certain values then that's going
to change it will change the state here
for our active section
so then for each one of these we're
gonna have to have some sort of check to
say if the active section corresponds to
this this section that's represented by
by these labels then we're gonna want to
make it bold or something I actually
haven't even decided with the what the
indicator is going to be does that make
sense
okay I know there's a delay so give
everybody like 30 seconds to respond I
don't want to lose anyone so let me know
if it doesn't make sense but that's what
we'll be working on okay Patrick I just
I saw your comment about the the warning
so at 31st he is like okay cool so
Patrick's saying that these these that
he put the first line that he put up
here was to take care of the areas that
I'm seeing in the console step but mr.
fun
I'm just gonna clean things up a bit and
then I'll check the live chat before we
go move on
now that I look at this I think we're
we're really not using very much of the
functionality at all of this stepper
essentially it's just providing us with
just kind of the layout of a list of
things vertically so I guess we didn't
really need to use the separ we'll see
once we're finished with it once we're
finished with that we may be able to
just switch these over to divs or a
maybe a ul and it would probably work
especially since we have this we have
some of the styles here too
guess we don't need the back button
there Styles action I don't think we
even have the actions anymore
I'm not sure what part was the content
let's see
okay yeah that's the list here that
works this is drops
oh here we go forgot to take this one up
hmm who did
yeah we're definitely not even really
using most of what's going on with this
with this stepper
so let's just get rid of this
okay and still
there we go
you will see I'm just was trying to get
rid of some of these errors these crops
from the element planting I had one of
four I thought I removed all of those I
can't find them
[Music]
well maybe now might be the best time to
just switch this over from this step to
ul
yes
yeah I think that'll be the way to go so
let's get rid of this
I mean why why import you know this
component if we're not even really using
it so I mean this was kind of useful
just to help frame how we were going to
think about this but now it's pretty
obvious that this is not going to be
necessary
okay and that should take care of great
so you took care of those little lines
which is pretty awesome so we'll need to
add a little bit of padding and
everything but much better we're gonna
get rid of Stefan stuff here define I've
never used yeah there we go
get rid of that okay so now get rid of
those error messages and the click yeah
so this still works so everything that
we've done with clicking still works
great all right I said I was going to
check the live chat quickly so I'm gonna
do that now yeah so let me just check
the live chat now since I started this
timer late anyway so we're gonna do the
five minutes if you're not familiar with
with this stream and haven't seen it
before we do Pomodoro's
timer so 25 minutes of coding five
minutes I check the live chat we do that
maybe two or three times and then we
finish up and the last part of the
stream is just cue a question-and-answer
see
so I'm just gonna scroll up a bit and
see what I missed
so someone asked if angularjs is worth
learning I just say it depends on what
would you want to learn if you're
interested in that if there's jobs if at
a certain company you know that uses
angular then it's definitely worth
learning depends also you know how much
time you have if you have a lot of time
you know go ahead and and learn it you
know you could learn it without even
really having a good reason to yeah but
it just definitely depends on what
you're what you're trying to do Blake
also at Blake asked brackets i over
PSA's vs code it's a Visual Studio code
so I don't know I've never used brackets
so I can't really compare I have used
Visual Studio code and I like it but
like I said since I haven't used
brackets I can't really answer that
question
braxton says hey Jessie how's it going
I'm doing all right huh how's everything
going with you thanks for watching okay
Rohan has a good question
Rohan says I know you have a job
currently but if you were to change jobs
or go freelance again would you
advertise yourself as a reactive or
front-end slash full-stack
yeah I wonder I
I guess I would feel comfortable at this
point calling myself a reactive that's
not to say I think I'm an expert at
react but I've been developing sites
you'll react sites for a while so I
would do that I'm deaf obviously I'm
comfortable with front-end I don't know
about full stack I'm getting more
confident at at doing things other than
front-end so I don't know I'd have to do
a little bit more with back-end before I
be comfortable saying full stack but I
don't think I'm that far away from from
being able to say that honestly so maybe
I guess it would just depend on what
what I really wanted to do if I read if
I knew I really wanted to do react which
at this point I I really like react so I
may end up just saying reactive yeah I
may I may do react because I I would
like that and then just for the type of
company react is is somewhat new so I
would know that if there is a company
that is using react and they're looking
specifically for react dev the odds of
them being open to adopting new things
like sooner are probably greater than a
company that is just looking for a front
end of and you know who knows they could
be using you know in anything so I guess
it would for me at least I'd like to
have a job where I'm you know I'm
somewhere the
comfortable trying new things and trying
to stay you know as cutting edge as is
reasonable so I guess the answer the
question right now after I've thought
about it is I think I would market
myself as a react dev
okay then I just saw your comments about
the material UI components and all the
props so I mean I guess at this point it
doesn't matter but thank you for for
letting me know about that break point
asks why are you implementing scroll
instead of the anchor we're doing the
scroll well basically it's easy to get
it so my times up here so let me let me
start this again but this is a good
segue back into the code so the the
reason I went with the scroll instead of
the anchor so I originally I was
planning on doing the anchor and I think
I had yeah so I even added in IDs
thinking that I would go with the anchor
but I really don't need the idea is now
because we end up going with this index
and since we've indexed the positions
the header positions here then when we
click on these it's easier just to go by
the index I I think it's easier just go
by the index at this point especially if
we were to let's say like create these
dynamically okay so that's one reason is
it was just easier when I was doing this
to say like okay we have the value
stored in an array so let's just go with
the index the second reason though is if
I want to implement some sort of smooth
scrolling feature I know I don't know
like I said I need to go back and look
at how I've done this in the past but I
think it will be easier to implement by
the position because I believe what I've
done in the past is gotten the ID
determine what the position was and then
set up scrolling based on the position
anyway so and
in that scenario it wouldn't really
matter you know we wouldn't be using the
anchor to navigate so does that make
sense
I mean maybe I'm thinking about this
wrong and you know maybe it'll be
clearer later on for me but probably
what will end up happening is I'll I'll
have some sort of like smooth scrolling
happen and it'll be more beneficial for
me to know the position anyway
okay I was just checking the the last
little bit there and in the latch at
okay so I didn't get through everything
so I'll come back after this Pomodoro
session and I'll start back you know
right with the comments right after we
talked about using the anchor so so any
comments made after 226 p.m. Eastern
Time
I will get to those in about 20 minutes
all right so let's move on I really
think we can get this working before we
finish so that's the goal today I'm not
worried about having its style 100%
properly but at least having it
functional I think it's a good goal and
it's definitely reasonable
okay so let's do our we're gonna do this
on handle scroll right now I want to do
this on handle scroll because it's being
throttled right so we're tracking the
scroll we have our event listener but
we're only calling handle scroll every
you know 200 milliseconds so this is
where we want it let's do
all right let's do a switch statement
I'm gonna have to look up on my other
screen how to do a switch statement
because I have not typed out a switch
statement in a long time I remember when
I was first learning how to do a switch
statement I made a text-based game and
depending on how you answered the
questions it did different things and it
was just one big switch statement I
think it's on my github yeah I think I
did put it on github it was like a Lord
of the Rings kind of game and I think it
used alerts yeah so it's probably I
haven't looked at it in years it's
probably pretty terrible but the whole
point was for me to learn how to use a
switch statement all right so on my
other screen I just opened up the ND mdn
page on switch statements and I'm just
gonna paste in there example to say
sometime alright great so the switch
statement is we're gonna pass in the
scroll wide yeah we're gonna pass in
scroll why
scroll why and then the first case is
going to be
I see you scroll I actually let me see
this
I guess it would be
oops
yeah we won't even really need the first
value at all since the top of the page
who have it highlighted so we'll just
skip right to the neck the second value
so if wait a second I need to read let
me take five seconds to read about
switch statements because like totally
just drawing a blank
with how to do a switch statement so
what I want to do basically is something
like if the first case will be is if
scroll Scroll Y is less than now
yeah if scroll Y is greater than
header this state header physicians one
they were it
okay so you know I'm trying to do
okay let me try it like this
okay this is how I think it would work
all right so for the switch I want it to
match true right so if this is true then
it's gonna do what's in here right does
that make that makes more sense we'll
find out in a few seconds so for now why
did they put these brakes let me get rid
of these or at least that's and I do
want this default so
one
oops
to
let's see this is greater than
let's see
I think I'm doing this backwards from
what it should be
so what I should ever do is if it's less
than the first position then it's going
to be header one there we go if it's
less than the second then it's going to
be oh yeah header header two
three and then this last case will be
for
three
do you think suppose someone lets
everyone listen to all right let's try
this out what did I do
all right so let's see what we get okay
cool so four three two one
alright so normally if someone would
start at the top of the page there at
the top of the page let's see as we go
down having one that's cool 1 1 1 1 1
now we switch to 2 right there perfect
yeah that's where we want to switch and
now 3 and finally 4
all right cool so that works just like
we want it to work now we just need to
switch it out instead of consult logging
we need to highlight one of these
depending on where we're at on the page
so let's do that so I think
it's the best way to do this
I think if I can put
I do this
I don't think I can I was trying to put
a ternary in style but I'm pretty sure
you can't do that can you put one inside
an element let's see I don't know if
I've ever tried this before let's just
try it and see what happens
so actually see we want
step content I don't think we need this
anymore right yeah let's get rid of that
I didn't realize I already had a switch
statement on the page that would have
would have simplified things okay so
let's do something here so active
okay I already have active section okay
cool so actually to test this all I need
to do is is active section
see if I can do this
I don't think this is gonna work but
let's see
we
let's see now I knew I'd get in there
alright let's see
let's check the live chat really quick
alright nothing in there okay so good to
know we can't do this we can't do this
so let's see
at least I can see if I like the font
weight all right so that's that's not I
think at least can see the difference in
it I do it here actually this is toship
this is an object
if I could do it in here
I don't think this will work either this
would be the last silly thing I tried
that
Oh needs to be this state active section
whoa
did that really work actually so it kind
of worked
let me try it on another one
[Applause]
okay yeah it doesn't work what I was
trying to do was check to see if the
active section equal zero then oh yeah
wait a second maybe it did work and I
just I just did it wrong okay cool so
that like I said it kind of works
because it doesn't update see should I
do this
let's see
all right so what uh what I'm trying to
do which was probably obvious is I want
to change the font weight based on where
we're at on the page
Oh have I not changed active section yet
yeah oh all right that was silly I
haven't actually changed that to section
so this is this sad state
[Music]
this may end up working this one too so
right now there are a lot of things
hard-coded in here that could probably
be done in a more automatically I guess
but for now it's this works
oh look at that it worked a little bit I
didn't put it on the other ones yet all
right so check that out we have the
highlighting its changing awesome let's
put that on these other guys
alright so cool so this is really good
to know I hope I remember this next time
I try it because I know I've done this
before and went through the same thing
if you're trying to apply a certain
style to an element in line if you try
to put the entire style object you know
inside this ternary it does not work but
if you inside that object since this is
just JavaScript anyway for the value and
the key value pair if you put the
ternary there then it works so if you're
not familiar with this this is like I
don't what they call it one of you are
the one that that showed me how to do
this it may have been Patrick and I
think you call it like a short-circuit
or something like that so basically it's
like we're checking to see if this if
the active section is equal to zero
instead of putting you know let's say
the question mark and then 500 and then
a colon and putting out of the default
font weight value there we can just say
we just put this in here basically and
then so whatever happens after that is
just gonna happen you know automatically
if this is true and if it's false
nothing happens right because if it's
false it's it doesn't go any further
right so
anyway so it's just a little shortcut so
let's put these here and here and two
three I just got the feeling like I
recreated a lot of what that stepper
already did but oh well it works cool
and see see so this is working
oh no I don't know if you saw that so if
I click on one the other ones still
highlighted I think what we need to do
in our switch statement then is put
equal to less than or equal to for all
these and that should fix it so let's
double check
I know it doesn't if we move down just a
bit hmm
less than equal to
oh no now we don't need me equal to
let's see
and position
listen
I think if I had just adjusted like this
let's see
there we go so that was enough so if we
just adjusted it so it's one pixel less
than that that solved the problem
because when we click it is taking us
exactly to where that is so there we go
all right awesome and that was pretty
good timing because this just beeped
about a minute ago so I'm gonna do the
five minutes let me check the time
actually I might I might wrap things up
now and just check the live chat do a
little question answer now because we
basically accomplished what we wanted to
for this I'm obviously not gonna leave
it like this style wise so I'm gonna get
rid of these these discs the bullet
points I'm gonna get rid of I'm gonna
make these let's see if that font size I
think this could do with a bit bigger
font size obviously some better spacing
between these and maybe maybe something
more pronounced here to show what
section you're on I'm thinking like
possibly a a very small left border that
moves as we go up and down and that
would that border could be our accent
our current accent color which is this
yellow
yeah I think that'll that'll look look a
lot better also we're gonna want to set
our cursor to pointer when it goes over
these just to give a visual indication
that this these are clickable all right
yeah that's that sounds like that'll
that'll look good so I'll probably work
on that maybe before I leave
actually I've been meaning to stop at
the post office for like a week or two
and I never get out of work in enough
time before the post office closes so I
may be leaving a bit early earlier than
normal to be able to make it to the post
office so if I don't get this to this
today than Monday morning I'll make
those changes
so the code portion of this stream is
done so if you just wanted to stick
around for the code now that was a good
time to to leave and totally understand
if you got some other stuff you need to
do thank you so much for watching I'll
be back on Monday if you can stick
around for the question and answer that
would be great even if you don't have a
question I'd really like your input and
a live chat to help answer some some of
the questions that we get so so right
now I'm gonna scroll back up to where we
left off at so if you have any questions
put them in the live chat quickly
because once I get to the bottom we'll
wrap things up and in the stream if you
can't stick around to hear the answer to
your question you can check out the
replay of this this video the recording
and that will be available on the free
code camp Channel you could also send me
a message on Twitter or any other social
media platform that you like and I'll
try to answer your question there as
soon as I get a chance
okay
okay I think I found where I left off at
and I'm not going to read out everything
in the live chat but the questions
especially questions from from people
who are new I definitely want to try to
get to those questions and make sure
everyone feels welcome
okay Blake said Blake it asks a question
about bracket zero versus Visual Studio
code and he says brackets tayo does not
work with github repos so string did do
you mean that it doesn't have and it
doesn't reflect any of the the state of
of get like visually in there I'm not
exactly sure what you mean by that so I
guess let me know I probably won't be
switching editors but it would be good
to know maybe especially if there's
other people watching that may be
considering it
dinesh asks is Redux mandatory and been
been said no but it is recommended it's
pretty standard pattern for react yeah
for sure I've I've actually I'm building
a react project with Redux right now and
it's it's just like a react blog you can
post you new blog posts and comment and
vote on comments and on posts and I'm
doing that for the Udacity react nano
degree I'm using Redux for that but I've
actually never used Redux for any of my
other react projects so yeah it's
definitely not mandatory but now that
I'm learning it I can see that it would
give you a big advantage and keeping
keeping track of especially if you had a
bigger project things could get things
get a little bit crazy with trying to
pass state down through so many child
components yeah it would Redux makes
things a lot easier to reason about so
anyway I definitely recommend it unless
unless you're doing a really small
project then you probably don't need
Redux but otherwise it's probably good
idea to use Redux or I mean there are
other alternatives to Redux too that you
could use Jess Quran asks which is the
best channel to keep yourself updated
related to web then says these videos
are using pretty up-to-date stuff and
level up I don't know I always don't
know how people pronounce this but I
always say level up Tut's
so - UTS but he says it's it's a good
it's also good for some of the newer
things cool yeah I mean I would I I try
to do newer stuff when I can I mean I
don't I don't use new stuff just to use
it because it's new and if it has to be
of some value to the project but I real
I tried to do something new on every
project that I that I use so even if you
know most of my projects are probably
gonna be react there's some things that
I may need to work on where I can't use
react because of I have to work it
within an existing system but I am gonna
try to use some new technology that I've
never used before so I guess I guess you
know Ben's right this will normally be
pretty up-to-date
looks like there's there's some decent
discussion on the merits of Visual
Studio code versus brackets
okay and it looks like I've got some a
clearer picture so what Blake was
meaning by github and and brackets is
the git integration is is not great
so it evidently it breaks live reload if
you using it so like I said I don't know
I don't use it so I'm not I'm not
exactly sure but anybody anybody that
uses brackets maybe if you could help
out in the live set or in the comments
to this video and see if you had any
trouble using get with the live preview
if so have you found anywhere to work
around that or get get it to work
Rowland earlier I commented on a on a
JavaScript text-based game that I had
made that was I was trying to learn how
to do switch statements and I mentioned
that I used JavaScript alerts for it and
Rohan says JavaScript alerts used and
loved by scammers and learner's alike
indeed yes I really want to go back and
play that game now I I think I actually
have either a code pen or something on
jsfiddle I'm gonna have to go back and
look at that that repo
because now now I'm just curious it's
always it's fun to look at previous
projects and just kind of see just like
whoa see what you were thinking or how
far you've come here it is I'm moving it
onto the screen right now I'm just gonna
show you oh so you can see look how
simple it is one javascript file and to
read me at least I put in a readme that
I mean that's pretty good this was
probably one of the first things I ever
used github for let's see the sewers
okay yeah so you can see this big switch
switch statement
yeah defeated you are cool so anyway
actually it's not as big as I thought it
seemed really big at the time so that's
my JavaScript game I should have saved
that for like Thursday I could have done
throwback Thursday or that project but
anyway yeah feel free to play that
whenever you want it's super fun you can
you can get through all the game content
in less than a minute if anyone who is a
lawyer for the Tolkien estate and you
see this don't don't sue me I'll take it
down if you want me to
all right Patrick said sorry Patrick I
didn't see this comment this was a while
ago he said I don't think that's a great
place for a switch statement
so I guess let me know I'm probably not
gonna change it right now but let me
know where else would you put the switch
you know we I guess
should I just kind of extract this out
of here and then I guess I could make
this into a function in return no I
wouldn't need to return anything would I
because it's already doing what it needs
to do anyway let me know where where I
should put it in Y and that would be
helpful it would be helpful for me and
maybe for other people watching as well
actually there's there's not really a
question made more of a discussion going
on about using a using it through the
terminal or using a graphical user
interface forget so I like github as a
git client for the desktop I'm
interested I mean what do you all prefer
obviously I use the terminal I've never
used the the desktop app for github
before is it better for some things I
tell you what figuring out like merging
things I could see how merging might be
better with a better interface and
definitely trying to do like like you
get diff would be potentially easier
with a graphical interface but since I
already am doing things with the
terminal it's just so much easier to do
everything in the terminal I think and
then once you remember all the commands
it's so much faster
Patrick says this is the most convoluted
use of a switch statement I think I've
ever seen impressive thanks Patrick
yeah if anyone has ideas to refactor
this let me know I'm definitely not we
don't have to stick with this it's just
the first thing that came into my head
to deal with that
patrick said i once had to refactor and
maintain a pearl cgi shopping cart
written by a graphic designer as one
giant switch statement haha
I would like to see that I would not
like to have to maintain that but it
would be cool to see it Mitchell says hi
guys this is a nice way to learn never
thought of live coding hey how's it
going not sure if you're still still
watching but thanks for watching
okay Patrick says don't set state twice
and handle scroll combine the scroll y1
so I then to put this scroll Y part in
here so that set state only runs
essentially once each time this is
called
okay Patrick is saying I build a new
object in the switch and then set State
at the end with scroll Y included okay
that makes sense so I would then only
call set State down here and it would
include whatever whatever info I need
and the scroll Y in an object all right
that's that's cool I said I'm not gonna
make any changes right now but that does
make a lot of sense
Patrick asks what am I going to do with
the menu on small screens I'm just gonna
hide it on small screens I don't really
know I can't think of a good way to
display that on a really small screen so
I was just gonna leave it off if anyone
has any ideas for how to display a menu
like that so this type of side menu when
a screen gets really small let me know
but I I don't know I think it would just
be better I mean it'll be a lot of
scrolling but it would be better to just
leave the space for the text I think
although what I made when I may have
available though is a an arrow maybe to
go to get to the top of the page
Oh we'll see actually you know what I am
gonna try to implement it so that if you
scroll up a little bit the header then
appears wherever you're at so that that
would eliminate the need to put that
arrow to scroll away up to the top yeah
I think we yeah we had talked about that
earlier in the week I think
John Hanson said it's amazing so much
goes into a small UI function yeah can
you believe that I mean I thought about
that this morning and like I can't
believe I'm still working on this part
like it looks so small and that's it's
really hard sometimes to people who have
no idea of what goes into making
something like this would potentially
think like oh you just add this little
thing you know that's what like an hour
less than an hour to do that it seems
like a small thing but it's really not
so I found that with with clients before
with people here at the University that
that there's very little understanding
of how thing how long things actually
take so occasionally someone will ask
for something and it immediately be
dismissed is all that'll take forever
but really it's not a big deal and I can
get it done quickly and then other times
the last or something that they think is
a very small thing and I have to explain
like well actually that's that's going
to take a long time so anyway I guess
that's just how it is I'm sure it's like
that with other professions as well
unless you really know what goes into
something then you won't really have an
idea of how long it'll take
so we have a question so I started to
use Redux recently in the fields that
it's very hard to divide components and
smart and dumb how do you make it
yeah
I don't know I guess I don't have I
haven't really had
so basically smart and dumb components
we talk about stateless and stateful
components right so components that have
state and that needs state and then
components that don't I don't know I
guess I haven't really had problems in
dividing them because it's I mean
usually you know if your component needs
to do something or change based on user
action then it's probably going to need
state if we're talking about Redux then
most of your state should live in the
store and redux right so you shouldn't
have this separate component state but I
will say if you have components that are
really simple like that the state is
basically just for UI right so in this
case I don't know that I would store the
state to make this thing work in this in
the store in Redux this would probably
be something that I would keep at the
component level at component level
States I'm not exactly sure if this is
what you're asking so hopefully this
helps though so this is something where
you know this state is not going to need
to be known you know by other components
right it's not it's not shared right so
anytime you have a shared state that
more than one component needs to know
about that state it should definitely be
in the store but like if you have
something that only one component needs
and especially if it's just like UI
related right in this case we're just
changing the whole point of pretty much
everything that we've done here was just
to make this a slightly you know higher
font weight so I would keep that
at the component state sooner
sorry if you have a worth worked on
Redux that might not have made very much
sense to you sorry about that
hopefully the next project we can use
Redux and then that'll be a nice if you
haven't worked with it'll be a nice
introduction if you're just starting out
with it then hopefully we can we can
learn and get better with it together
I John Hansen asks our empty div section
main etc wrong thing to build into react
components making them are usable when I
tried to do this components like figure
image figcaption nested inside the above
don't show em actually I don't I don't
know I am
I don't know that I've ever tried to
make like empty sections basically
layout components right yeah I don't
know that I've tried to make that are
you using what would it be it would be
children so within I would check out two
things I would check out maybe two to
see so in our last project which is the
repo is called CI react or maybe react
CI either way there's a layout component
that essentially does somewhat of what
you're talking about
so check out how that's done and then
also if you look at the materialize is
it materialized no the latest version of
material UI so the the very newest
version that we attempted to use it
first and then decided to switch back I
think they have some layout components
like that that are just basically empty
sections for their grid view I would
check that out as well and see how they
implement that so I don't think it would
be wrong to do that I could definitely
see value in that especially if if you
want to use them as layout components it
almost reminds me of in WordPress they
have these shortcodes and they have
short codes for layout which normally
you would just do with divs but I mean
if you've worked with short codes in
WordPress you know what I'm talking
about but essentially they would serve
the same purpose so anyway those two
places might be a good place to kind of
look into it and see how that's being
done in you know in other ways
oh cool cough will says West boss has a
Redux course and it's free so that's
awesome I'm gonna have to check that out
like I said I'm learning Redux through
the Udacity react nano degree right now
but maybe that would be a good resource
to use alongside of it and give me a
better understanding hey I'm there so
congratulations so Umberto who's
regularly in the live set says that he
just received part one of an interview
process for a Java developer position
that's awesome good luck with with the
whole process and that's that's really
good I'm really happy for you definitely
let us know how things go
okay so so someone I'm I can't read and
how to pronounce your name so I'm sorry
about this
I think I'm assuming that's in Russian
let me try to translate I'm going to
show you a chance like this I can
actually say the right name
alright so Google Translate is saying
it's a bulat sorry if that's wrong I'm
just going by Google Translate so uh so
I'm gonna say bulat it says recently I
got a job as a react native developer
but on the previous job I coded 2d games
with phaser j/s how much time and I need
to afford to be comfortable with react
development I guess it just depends on
like how how much time per day can you
dedicate to it to learning it how fast
of a learner are you you know things
like that so it's really hard to say you
know it's it's more of an individual
thing but I've I think I'm pretty
comfortable with react right now I mean
I'm comfortable enough that I can create
websites that are that are going to be
used by clients by the university I'm
comfortable enough to live code in react
I guess and I think I started my first
real react projects last winter so maybe
the beginning of winter in 2016 so it
hasn't even been a year yet and during
that time I haven't dedicated all my
time to react either so I've had to work
on other things that weren't react so I
would say like potentially you know
within a few months you know you could
start you'd be really comfortable with
it but I
and it really does depend on your
situation and your your capacity to pick
up new things all right Patrick says I
actually like the switch statement you
wrote so thanks Patrick
okay so David says the desktop clients
for forget are good for seeing the
history of a repo especially multiple
people are working on it that's cool
yeah definitely I didn't even think
about that but that's that's definitely
I would be useful as well
okay here's some ideas for what to do
with this with this on a smaller screen
so Rowan said could it be a right slide
out actually that's that's possible I
think I think I remember that doing like
a side and that thing like this on this
side was very easy just basically you
just change a prop and to add another
one so yeah that yeah that could
definitely work yes I'll think about
that also Thomas says we're fixed fixed
to the top yeah I could do that too
I don't want to really don't want to
take up too much space we'll just have
to try some things out on mobile like
I'm not really actually what I should do
I'm gonna check out the analytics right
because we're redoing something that's
already live I want to check the
analytics and see what people are using
when they go there if it turns out that
there's a very small percentage of
people visiting this on their mobile
phones then I'll probably just end up
completely hiding this if it's a large
percentage then maybe I'll you know try
out some other ways to mean it to make
this work on a small screen but it may
not be the best use of our time to
really you know do a lot more with this
for smaller screens if there's not
really many people using the smaller
screens probably good to check the
analytics anyway and just to see you
know perhaps we need to test this on
certain browsers that are being used
frequently as well
Oh awesome so bula says the translation
was correct so in it in he is from
Russia so cool I'm really glad it's
correct and why I'm a little bit nervous
Google Translate is normally really good
but I'm always a bit nervous that it'll
like mess up when somebody's trying to
say so so that's cool I'm glad that I'm
glad they got it right okay yeah so I
think I've got through all the questions
now and yeah okay so it's almost four
o'clock Eastern Time where I'm at and I
really need to get to the post office
before they close they close in an hour
so now it's a great time to wrap things
up thank you so much for all your help
in the live chat and and just for
watching I really appreciate it I think
you know we got this working and I'm
happy with the way it's working just
needs a bit of styling to look really
nice and think I'll be back Monday let
me double check
just to give you kind of an advanced
heads-up if I need yeah it looks like I
don't have anything on the calendar for
Monday afternoon so unless something
else comes up some meeting I should be
at the same time I think I do have a
meeting at 3:00 that I didn't put on my
calendar so it'd probably be a short
stream on Monday maybe I might take a
day off next week
and take my kids to a museum in
Pittsburgh but I'm not 100% sure about
that because some of my kids have been
sick lately so I don't want to take them
if they're still sick but anyway I'm
sure y'all don't need to know my oh my
my life right now but I have a wonderful
weekend hope everybody you know has an
enjoyable relaxing weekend or if you
have to work I hope it's productive for
you so I guess I'll see you on Monday
thanks again